hi i'm schloss fraser a second year
computational neuroscience phd student
and today i want to talk to you about
reading papers fast so do you also
always struggle with reading the
literature adding papers left and right
to your to be read list feeling
extremely overwhelmed in the weekends
because you assumed you would be reading
all these papers in the weekends and end
up not reading anything well i got you
today i want to talk about how i read
papers relatively fast and how i can get
through all the work that is being
published in neuroscience without
feeling super overwhelmed because i
think after two years of doing my phd i
finally found some methods and some tips
and tricks that really helped me reading
the papers that i have to read so i will
take you through them right now so i
think with reading papers there are
usually three things that we want so
first we want to read a lot of papers
such that we can keep up with all the
literature second we want to remember
what we have read because otherwise all
this reading doesn't really have any use
and firt we want to put all the papers
and everything we remember into the
bigger context of our scientific body or
our scientific literature world so first
of all i want to talk about how to read
a lot faster such that you can read
everything or everything you kind of
want to so i think most people that i
know read in this manner so it's a
technique to skim the paper so i'll put
up my second screen and kind of take you
through how i would approach a new paper
so the first thing i would do is to look
at the title and the abstract and to
decide quite fast if it's actually worth
reading the paper or if it's worth my
time because a lot of papers even though
they seem relevant perhaps are not that
relevant so it's your job to kind of
decide quite quickly if it's worth your
time and effort so i skim the title and
abstract and see kind of what results
are being presented in the paper and
then once i've decided to read the paper
or i think it's worth my time i
immediately look at the figures so i
usually don't read anything else at
first i usually just go straight to the
figures and in the figures you can
already see what kind of results they
have how they are presented what kind of
conclusions you can draw from it and it
depends a little bit on how much
knowledge you have in the field if you
need for example to read the
introduction or to actually read the
text with the results and the methods
but i'm now a little bit more further in
my phd journey so usually i can just
look at the figures and already know 95
of what's written in the paper so after
i've gone through all the figures i may
refer a little bit back to the results
and the methods but usually i go
straight to the discussion because i
think personally that the discussion is
the most interesting in a discussion
it's usually what the reviewers thought
of the paper for example and they point
out some critical points that have to be
bettered in the future or some further
research questions so usually by reading
this you can kind of think of some
questions yourself and that could
perhaps be the next paper for you to
write so i think in general this method
takes me about 30 minutes to skim
through papers really quickly and then
if i want to read them in more detail i
usually put them aside for later so then
the second step is to remember the
papers better that you've just read and
the way i do it i use notion of course
so i'll pull off my notion page so in
general in notion i made this page where
i put all the papers i read and you have
this web plugin in notion which you can
just link through your papers so if i
find the paper i will just click the web
plugin and put this directly into my
notion page then as i'm reading the
paper i usually make screenshots of
figures that i like and perhaps want to
reproduce in my own work so these i just
screenshot and put in the notion page
and then i also make little voice memos
and this i do with the notion app so i
put the notion app on my
phone this is not sponsored by notion by
the way but i just love notion a lot so
i put the notion app on my phone and
then i just record the voice memos on my
phone and i think by using voice memos
instead of typing out what i like about
the paper i usually get a little bit
more critical because sometimes when i'm
just typing as i'm reading the paper i
usually just retype what i just read
whereas when i use a voice memo i
usually have to think a little bit more
about my interpretation of what i read
and i think this works for me a lot
better to really understand what's being
written in the paper and what i like or
dislike about it yeah and then the last
step is to put everything into the
bigger context and i think this mostly
comes with experience but when you just
start out i think a good app that i use
a lot is research rabbit so research
rabbits makes these kind of beautiful
trees of how all the papers in a certain
topic are connected and i think this is
a really good way because you can
structure it by year for example but you
can also structure it by how they cite
each other and this just gives a really
nice tree-like overview of all the
papers in the field which then can help
you to select your next paper or to kind
of understand how your paper is placed
within wider bigger papers yeah and then
i have some final tips that i always use
when i'm reading a lot of papers first
of all is to use a paper reference
manager whenever people tell me they
don't use a paper reference manager i'm
so surprised because they are super good
for for example citing work or for
collecting all the papers you want to
read so in general i use zotero but i've
used manly in the past as well and i
think most of them work very similar so
i would just pick a free one that you
don't have to pay for and then the way i
do it when i find a paper i use the web
plugin of zotero and then it
automatically imports it in zotero and
then i put a little tag on it to be read
and i also have the colors for that so
red is for if i really need to read it
and orange if is for if i might want to
read it and then green if i read it and
this for me really works to put all the
papers or all the list of papers that i
want to read and not get so overwhelmed
then another tip i have is to set a set
reading time i kind of have this from
the tiny habit book and i think it's
quite important to have a set time in
your day at which you will be reading
and i don't think it necessarily has to
be papers but it's kind of good if it is
papers but by having this set time you
every day already read something like
five to ten pages and then by the end of
the week you already will have read plus
70 pages and i think this makes managing
all the things you have to read so much
easier than if you push everything to
one day and have to read 70 pages in one
day yeah so these are all the techniques
and tricks i've learned over the last
two years if you have any tips for me or
some apps that you really like to use i
would love to hear them so put them down
in the comments below and if you're now
writing your literature review i wish
you all the luck and see you next week
bye